The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JULIAN SHUN: Good
afternoon, everybody.
So welcome to the
third lecture of 6.172.
Today we're going to
talk about bit hacks,
and today's going to be
a really fun lecture.
So, first of all, let's recall
the binary representation
of a word.
So a w-bit word is
represented as follows.
So we're going to number the
bits from x0 to xw minus 1
starting from the
rightmost side.
And the unsigned
integer value stored
in x with this
binary representation
can be computed as follows.
So it's essentially the sum of
a whole bunch of powers of 2.
And you sum the product of the
bit with the appropriate power
of 2.
So if the bit is
1 in position k,
then you multiply by 2 to the k.
And if it's 0, then
you just add 0.
So, for example, let's say
we have this 8-bit word here.
And if we apply this
equation, we get--
first we get 2 because there is
one bit in the first position.
So we multiply 1 by
2 to 1, which is 2.
Then in the second
position, we also have a 1.
So we multiply 1 by 2
to the 2, which is 4.
And then we have 16 and 128.
So we just sum up all
of these powers of 2
and that gives us the
unsigned integer value.
And that 0b prefix here
represents a Boolean constant.
So that means we're going
to interpret this constant
as a Boolean value.
There's also signed integers.
So you can also represent
negative numbers, which
is useful, and this
is called the two's
complement representation.
And here's the
formula for computing
the two's complement
representation of a word.
So for bit 0 all the
way up to bit w minus 2,
you do the same thing as above.
But for the leftmost
bit or bit w minus 1,
you subtract that bit multiplied
by 2 to the w minus 1.
So for this example here,
we saw 2 plus 4 plus 16.
That's the same as above.
But for the leftmost bit,
since we have a 1 here,
we're going to subtract
2 the 7, which is 128.
And this gives us
the signed value
for the integer,
which is negative 106.
Does that make sense?
Any questions about
this representation?
So the leftmost bit
is known as a sign bit
because it tells you
whether you need to subtract
by this negative value or not.
So if it's 0, then you don't
have to subtract anything.
If it's 1, then you subtract
by a large integer value.
So in two's complement,
the all 0's word is just 0.
So you just apply the above
formula and everything is 0.
So you just get 0.
What's the value of
the all 1's word?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: 1.
JULIAN SHUN: Negative 1, right?
So the reason why it's
negative 1, so you can just
use the formula.
And we're going to sum up
a bunch of powers of 2.
All of the x sub k's
are going to be 1.
So we're summing up 2 to the k
from k equals 0 to w minus 2,
and that's a geometric series
which sums to 2 to the w
minus 1 minus 1.
And then for the
sign bit, we're going
to subtract 2 to the w minus 1.
So now the 2 to the w
minus 1's cancel out
and we're just left
with negative 1.
So this is an important
property to know about two's
complement representation.
The all 1's word
is just negative 1.
And this leads to important
identity which says that x plus
the one's complement of x-- the
one's complement is just all
the bits of x flipped--
is equal to negative 1.
This is because if you add x
with all of it bits flipped,
then you're just going to
end up with the all 1's word.
And we saw on the
previous slide that that's
equal to negative 1.
And from this identity,
we have that negative x
is equal to the one's
complement of x plus 1.
So this relates the
two's complement
to the one's complement
representation.
Let's look at an example.
So let's look at--
let's say x is equal
to this constant here.
The one's complement
of x or tilde of x
is just all of the
bits of x flipped.
And then to get
negative x, we add 1
to the one's complement of x.
And the fact of
adding 1 here is we're
going to take the rightmost 0
bit in the one's complement,
flip that to a 1.
And then for all of the
bits to the right of that,
we flip them to 0's.
So another way to
see this is you
look at the representation of
x and you flip all of the bits
up to the rightmost 1 but not
including that rightmost 1 bit,
and then you just
copy everything over.
So any questions about this?
OK.
So this is a table showing
the relationship between hex
and binary representation.
So hex representation
is base 16.
And the reason why we use
hex is because sometimes we
have these big binary constants
and we don't want to write--
have to type all of these
symbols into our code.
And hex gives us a
more compact format
to write these constants.
And this table, you
can basically just
look up, for each
possible hex value, what
its binary representation is.
And for the values
from 0 to 9, we're
just going to use the same as
decimal representation for hex.
And then for values
10 to 15, we're
going to use the
characters from A to F.
To translate from hex to binary,
you just take each hex digit,
look it up in this table, write
out the binary equivalent,
and then you
concatenate together
all of the binary
values you've got.
So in this example I
have this hex constant
which says DEC1DE2C0DE4F00D.
So now I just look up each of
these hex values in this table.
So D is 1101, E is 1110,
C is 1100, and so on.
And I just concatenate all
of these values together
and that gives me my
binary representation.
And you can also go
the other way around,
converting binary to hex.
And you do the same thing,
just look it up in this table.
And the prefix 0x here
designates a hex constant,
just like 0b designates
the Boolean constant.
So if you're using these
constants in your code
and you're writing
it in hex, then you
should use the 0x prefix.
So C has a bunch of
bitwise operators.
And here's a table
describing what
these bitwise operators do.
So the ampersand is
just logical AND.
The vertical bar is logical OR.
This caret sign is the
XOR or exclusive OR.
And XOR just says that if
either of the two bits is 1,
then we return 1.
And if both of the bits are
0 or both of them are 1,
then we return 0.
The tilde sign is the one's
complement or the not.
And then we have left shift
and right shift operators.
So let's look at how these
operatives work on this example
here.
So we have these
two 8-bit words,
A and B. To compute A AND B,
we just look at every two bits
in the same position
in A and B and compute
the AND of those two bits.
So 1 ANDed with 0 is
0, so we get 0 here.
0 ANDed with 1 is 0.
1 ended with 1 is 1, and so on.
A OR B is similar but now
you apply the OR operator
instead of the AND operator.
So if either one of
the two positions is 1,
then you return 1.
And if both are 0,
then you return 0.
So an A OR B, all of the
bits except for this bit here
is 0 because in the
original two words
both of the corresponding
bits were 0.
For A XOR B, we check if exactly
one of the two bits is 1.
So for the leftmost
bit, we have 1 and 0,
so we have exactly one bit
set to 1 and we get a 1 here.
The second bit is 0
and 1, so that's 1.
The third bit is 1, 1,
so that's 0, and so on.
Tilde of A is just the one's
complement of A. We saw
that before.
We just flip all the bits.
A right shifted by 3, we
just shift the bit string
to the right by 3, and then we
fill in the digits or the bits
on the left with 0's.
And then A left shifted
with 2, we do the same thing
but to the left.
And then we fill in these
empty bits with 0's.
So these are the bitwise
operators in C. Any questions?
AUDIENCE: They're
not [INAUDIBLE]??
JULIAN SHUN: For a right
shift, there is a--
there is a shift that will
fill in the upper digits
with whatever the
leftmost digit was.
But if you're working
with unsigned integers,
then it's not going to do that.
For signed integers it will.
And when we're doing
bit manipulations,
we're usually going to
stick to unsigned integers,
so we don't have to
worry about that.
So now let's look at
some common idioms
that you can do using
these bitwise operators.
So the first one we'll
look at is setting
the kth bit in a word x to 1.
So the idea here is to use
a shift followed by an OR.
So we're going to compute
1 left-shift it by k if we
want to set the kth bit to a 1.
And this gives us a mask with a
1 in exactly the kth position,
and 0's everywhere else.
And then now when
we OR that in to x,
that's going to change the bit
from a 0 to a 1 if it was a 0.
And if that bit was
already set to 1,
then this doesn't do anything.
And then for all of
the other positions,
since we're doing
an OR with 0, we're
just copying over
the bits from x.
So that's setting the kth bit.
We can also clear the kth bit.
And the idea here is to use a
shift, a complement, and then
an AND.
So again we're going to generate
this mask, 1 left-shifted by k.
But now we're going to take
the complement of this.
So now we have a 0 in exactly
the kth position and 1's
everywhere else.
And now when we AND this mask
with x, in the kth position
it's going to clear
that bit because we're
ANDing it with a 0.
So the result is going
to be 0 no matter
what was there before.
And then for all
the remaining bits,
since we're ANDing with 1,
we're just copying it over
from the original word.
You can toggle the kth
bit or flip the kth bit
using a shift and then an XOR.
So, again, we're going
to generate this mask.
And then now, when we do
an XOR with this mask,
it's going to change a bit from
a 0 to 1, or from a 1 to a 0,
because that's what XOR does.
So in this example, it's
changing from a 0 to 1.
But if it was already
a 1, then it's
going to toggle it back to 0.
Any questions?
So let's look at
another bit trick.
So here we're trying to extract
a bit field from a word x.
And this is important if you're
working with encoded data.
And the idea here is to
do a mask and a shift.
So we're going to generate
a mask with 1's in exactly
the positions that we want
to extract out of this word,
and then 0's everywhere else.
And then we're going to
AND the x with the mask,
and that's going to give us
the bits in the four positions
that we wanted to
extract in this example,
and then we have
0's everywhere else.
And then now we're going
to right-shift this value
that we extracted so that
it appears in the least
significant digits so that we
can use it in our computation.
So this is a very
useful bit trick
to know if you're working with
compressed or encoded data.
And if you use the bit
field facilities in C,
it's actually going to generate
assembly code that will do
masking and shifting for you.
You can also set a
bit field in a word.
So let's say we want to set a
bit field in x to some value y.
The idea is to first invert
this mask to clear those bits
we want to set in x.
And then we OR in the
shifted value of y.
So let's say we have these
two words, x and y here.
We're going to generate
the mask as we did before,
but now we're going to flip
all the bits in the mask
by taking the one's complement.
And then we AND the--
we AND the one's
complement of the mask
with x, and that's going to
clear the bits in x because we
have 0's in exactly those
positions in that mask,
and when you AND that into
x it will return to 0.
And then for all
the other positions,
we're just copying
in the bits of x.
And then, finally, we're
going to left-shift y
by an appropriate
amount so that we
can line up the value with
these four bit positions here.
And then we can now
just OR those values in.
And this will set the
positions in x to the value y.
In order to be safe,
you should actually
do a mask on the shifted y
value before you OR it in,
because you don't know
that the value of y
is within the range of the mask.
So if y has some garbage
values in the higher bits,
when you OR this
in it might pollute
the original value of x.
So, for safety,
you should actually
do a mask before you OR the
value, the shifted value of y
in.
So any questions on this?
So now let's look at how
we can swap two integers.
So we want to swap
the values of x and y.
The standard way to do this is
to use a temporary variable t.
So we set t equal to x, x equal
to y, and then y equal to t.
This does involve a
temporary variable, however.
So now the question
is whether we
can do a swap without
using a temporary variable.
It turns out that you
can using bit tricks.
So here's the code for
doing a no-temp swap.
So you first set
x equal to x XOR
y, then y equal to x XOR y,
and then x equal to x XOR y.
So has anyone seen this before?
OK, good.
So some of you have
seen this before.
And for the rest
of you all, I'll
tell you how it works in
the next couple slides.
So let's first
look at an example
of how to run this
code before we
go into why it actually works.
So we're going to start with
these two words in x and y.
We're first going to
do x equal x XOR y.
And now we store
the result in x.
And this is the result when you
do the XOR of these two words.
And then now we do
y equal to x XOR y.
And notice how the value of
x here has already changed.
So we're doing the
XOR of these two words
and setting that to y.
And here this value is
actually the same as x.
So we've already placed x in y.
And, finally, we do another XOR.
We set x equal to x XOR y.
And then this gives us
this value, which is y.
So at the end,
we've just swapped
x and y without using
any temporary variable.
So the reason why this works is
because XOR is its own inverse.
So if you do x XOR y, and then
XOR the result of that with y,
you just get back x itself.
So let's look at the truth
table to see why this is true.
So in the x and y columns, I've
shown all the possibilities.
So there are four different
possibilities of x and y.
And then I also have
the values of x XOR y.
So it's 1 in the rows
where I have exactly one 1,
and then 0 in the
remaining rows.
And then now if I do
x XOR y XORed with y,
I'm going to XOR
these values with y.
0 XOR 0 is 0.
1 XOR 1 is 0.
1 XOR 0 is 1.
And 0 XOR 1 is 1.
And notice that these values
are the same as the values of x.
So when I XOR something in
twice, it just cancels out
and I get back the
original thing.
So now let's go into why this
bit trick actually does a swap.
So in the first line,
what we're doing is
we're generating a mask with
1's where the bits in x and y
differ.
Because that's what XOR
is going to give you.
It's going to return a 1
if the bits are different,
and 0 otherwise.
So this is a mask that
tells us in which positions
the bits in x and y differ.
And I'm going to
store that into x.
And then in the second
line, when I do x XOR y,
this is going to
flip the bits in y
that are different
from x, because I'm
XORing with this mask, which
tells me which of the bits
differ from x.
And then if I XOR
with that mask,
I'm flipping the bits
in y that differ from x,
and this will just
give me back x.
And I store that in y.
So we see that the original
value of x is in y now.
And then in the last line,
I do the same thing but now
I'm flipping the bits in x
that are different from y.
So I still have the
mask that's stored in x.
And then I can XOR
that mask with y,
and y has the
original value of x.
So this is flipping the bits
in x that differ from y,
and now I have the original
value of y stored in x.
So this is a pretty
cool trick, right?
Any questions on why this works?
So one thing about
this bit trick
here is that it's actually
poor at exploiting
instruction-level
parallelism, so it's actually
going to be slower than
the naive code that
uses a temporary variable.
Because in the
original code I had,
I could actually execute
two lines in parallel.
I can store value
into the temporary
and then also change
one of the values
of x and y at the same time.
Whereas in this
code here, there's
a sequential dependence
among these three lines.
I can't execute any of
the lines in parallel.
We'll learn more about
instruction-level parallelism
in next week's
lectures, but I just
wanted to point out that
the performance of this
isn't actually that great.
But this is actually a
pretty cool trick to know.
Sometimes it shows
up in job interviews.
So the next thing
we're going to look at
is finding the minimum
of two integers, x and y.
So let's say we want
to store the result
of the minimum in a variable r.
Here's the standard
way to do this.
We just use an
if-else statement.
So if x is less
than y, than r is x.
And, otherwise, r is set to y.
Here's an equivalent expression.
It just uses the
ternary operator in C.
It does exactly the same
thing as the if-else statement
on the left.
One performance
problem with this code
is that there is a
branch in the code.
So we have this
if statement that
checks if x is less than y.
And modern machines will
do branch prediction.
And for whatever branch it
predicts the code to take,
it's going to do
prefetching and execute some
of the instructions in advance.
But the problem is if it
mispredicts the branch,
it does a lot of wasted
work, and the processor
has to empty the pipeline
and undo all of the work
that it did.
So this is a performance issue
due to branch misprediction.
Modern compilers are
usually good enough
to optimize this branch away,
but sometimes the compiler
isn't good enough to
optimize the branch away.
So is there a way to do a
minimum without using a branch?
All right.
So here's how you do it.
So we set r equal to y XOR
x or y ANDed with negative x
less than y.
So it's pretty obvious, right?
So why does this work?
So first we need to know that
the C language represents
the Boolean values
true and false
with the integers 1
and 0, respectively.
So now let's look at
the two possible cases.
First, let's look at a case
where x is less than y,
and then we'll look
at the case where x
is greater than or equal to y.
So in the first case,
when x is less than y,
the comparison here x less
than y is going to return 1.
And then we're going
to negate that,
which gives us negative 1.
And recall from
earlier, negative 1
is the all 1's word in two's
complement representation.
So when we AND x XOR
y with all 1's word,
that just gives us x XOR y.
And now we're left
with y XOR x XOR y.
And we know that the--
we know that the inverse
of XOR is itself.
And therefore the two
y's cancel out here
and we're just left with x.
And in this case x is
indeed the minimum.
In the other case, we have x
greater than or equal to y.
Then the expression x less
than y is going to return 0.
Negative of 0 is still 0.
And then when we AND x XOR
y with 0, we're left with 0.
And this just gives us
y XOR 0, which is y.
And in this case y is the
minimum of the two integers.
So any questions?
So how many of you--
how many of you
knew this already?
Good.
So we learned
something new today.
So let's see how branches
work in a real function.
So here we're trying to merge
together two sorted arrays,
and this is a subroutine
that's used in merge sort
if you've seen it before.
So the inputs to this
function are three arrays.
So we want to merge
together arrays A and B
and store the result
in C. And then
we also pass the function the
sizes of A and B in na and nb.
So what does the
restrict keyword do here?
Does anyone know?
So the restrict keyword
tells the compiler
that this is going to be
the only pointer that can
point to that particular data.
And this enables the compiler
to do more optimizations.
So when you're writing
programs and you
know that there can only
be one pointer pointing
to specific pieces
of data, then you
can declare that
restrict keyword,
and this gives the compiler more
freedom to do optimizations.
So now let's look at
this procedure here.
So while the sizes of
A and B are nonzero,
we're going to go into
this if-else clause
and we're going to check if
the element pointed to by A is
less than or equal to the
element pointed to by B.
And if so, we're going to
store that element pointed to
by A into C. And then
we're going to increment
both the C and A pointers.
And then we're going
to decrement na.
This tells us that there's
one less element in A
that we need to merge in now.
And, otherwise, we do the same
thing but with array B and nb.
And if one of the two
arrays becomes empty,
then we go to one of these
two while loops at the bottom
and we just copy all
the remaining elements
in the non-empty
array into C. So here,
if na is greater than 0,
then A is a non-empty array,
and then we just copy the
remaining elements of A into C.
And, otherwise, we copy the
remaining elements of B into C.
So let's do a simple example.
Let's say we want to merge
these two arrays in green
into the blue array here.
So let's say the top array is
A, and the bottom array is B,
and the blue array is C.
So, initially, A and B
are pointing to the beginning
of these two green arrays.
And since both
arrays are non-empty,
we're going to compare the
first two elements here.
And we see that
3 is less than 4,
so we're going to place
3 into the array C.
And then we're going to
increment the pointer in A
to point to the next element.
And we're also going to
increment the pointer
C to point to the next slot.
Now we're going to
compare 4 and 12.
4 is less than 12, so we
place 4 into the array C,
and we increment array B. And
then we just keep doing this.
So 12 is less than 14.
14 is less than 19.
19 Is less than 21.
21 is less than 46.
And here 23 is less than 46.
And at this point, one of
the arrays becomes empty.
So B is empty now.
So now we get to the
second while loop.
And we see that A still
has elements in it,
and we just copy the remaining
elements in A into C.
And then we're done.
So that's how the standard code
for merging two sorted arrays
works.
So let's look at each
of these branches
to see if it's predictable.
So a predictable
branch is a branch
that most of the time it
returns the same answer,
and only rarely does it
return a different answer.
And an unpredictable branch is
one where it sometimes returns
one value and sometimes
returns another value
and you can't really predict it.
So let's look at
the first branch.
Does anyone know if this
branch is predictable?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: That would
be unpredictable
because it depends on
what input you're given.
JULIAN SHUN: So it turns out
that this branch is actually
predictable because it's going
to return true most of the time
except for the last time.
So it's only going to return
false when nb is equal to 0.
And at that point you're just
going to execute this once
and then you're done.
But most of the time nb
is going to be greater
than 0 when you
execute this, and we
call this a predictable branch.
What about the second one?
So--
AUDIENCE: Also predictable?
JULIAN SHUN: Yes.
So it's also predictable
for the same reason.
What about the third one?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: No.
Because we really-- if we
already knew which was bigger,
then we already have
the sorted array then.
JULIAN SHUN: Yes.
So this turns out
to be unpredictable
because we don't know the
values in A and B a priori.
So this condition
inside the if statement
is going to return true
about half of the time
because we don't know what
values are in A and B.
And that's going to be
an unpredictable branch
because it's going to return
true or false about 50/50.
What about the last one?
Yes.
Why?
AUDIENCE: Yes, because for
similar reasons of 1 and 2.
It's probably [INAUDIBLE].
JULIAN SHUN: Yes.
So it is predictable.
The reason why it's
predictable is that most
the time it's going
to return true.
And that once it
returns false you're
never going to look at that
again inside this function
call.
So it returns true
most of the time,
and we call that a
predictable branch.
So branches 1, 2, and 4
are OK because they're
predictable branches, but branch
3 is going to cause a problem.
It's an unpredictable branch,
and the hardware doesn't really
like this because it can't
do prefetching efficiently.
So to fix this, we can use our
no-branch minimum bit trick
that we learned a
couple slides ago.
So now what we're doing is we're
going to have a variable called
cmp which stores the
result of the comparison
between the first element of
A and the first element of B.
And then now we're going to
get the minimum of A and B
as follows.
It's the same bit trick
that we saw before.
So now the variable
min is going to store
the smaller of the
first element of A
and the first element
of B. And we also
have the result of
this comparison here.
So that's stored in cmp.
So first we're going to
place the minimum value in C.
And then, based on
the result of cmp,
we're going to increment one of
A or B. So if A was less than
or equal to B, then
cmp is going to be 1.
And A plus equal cmp is
going to increment A by 1.
And then B plus equal to not
cmp is going to not do anything,
because not cmp is 0.
And then for na, we're
going to decrement by cmp.
So it's going to be 1 if A
is less than or equal to B,
and 0 otherwise.
And then for nb, we're
going to decrement
by the not of the cmp.
So only one of these
two lines is actually
going to do something based on
the result of the comparison.
And then the rest of the
code is the same as before.
Any questions?
So now we've gotten rid of
this unpredictable branch
that we had before.
So one thing about
this optimization
is that it works well
on certain machines.
However, on modern machines,
using a good compiler
like Clang with
the minus O3 flag,
the branchless
version is usually
going to be slower than
the branching version
because the compiler is
actually smart enough
to get rid of the branch
inside the original version
of minimum.
There's this instruction called
cmov or a conditional move.
It's basically a
branchless instruction
for doing a comparison.
We'll learn more
about that next week.
So this trick actually
usually doesn't really work.
There might be some machines
and some compilers that works,
but most of the
time, the compiler
is better at optimizing
this code than you are.
So one of the
common themes so far
is that I've told you about
a really cool bit trick
and then I told you that
it doesn't really work.
So why are we even learning
about these bit tricks
then if they don't even work?
So first is because the compiler
does some of these bit tricks,
and it's helpful to understand
what these bit tricks are
so you can figure out what
the compiler is doing when
you look at the assembly code.
Secondly, sometimes the compiler
doesn't do these optimizations
for you and you have
to do it yourself.
Thirdly, many bit
hacks for words
extend naturally to
bit and word hacks
for vectors, which are widely
used in high-performance code.
So it's good to know
about these tricks.
These bit tricks also
arise in other domains.
And, finally, because they're
just fun to learn about.
And for project 1,
you'll be playing around
with some of these
bit tricks, so it's
good to know about these things
that I've talked about already.
Here I'll talk about a bit
trick that actually does work.
So here we're trying
to do modular addition.
So we want to do x plus y mod n.
And here let's assume that x
is between 0 and n minus 1,
and y is also between
0 and n minus 1.
So the standard way
to do this is just
to use the mod operator,
x plus y mod n.
However, this does
a division, which
is relatively expensive
compared to other operations
unless n is a power of 2.
But most of the
time, you don't know
if n is a power of
2 at compile time,
so the compiler can't
actually translate this
to a right shift operation, and
then it has to do a division.
So here's another way to do
it without using division.
So we're first going to set z
equal to the sum of x and y.
And then if z is
less than n, then
it's already within the range
and we can just return z.
If z is greater
than or equal to n,
well we know we can
be at most 2n minus 2
because x and y were
both at most n minus 1.
So all we have to do is to
subtract n and bring it back
into range.
However, this code has an
unpredictable branch here
because we don't know whether
z is less than n or not.
So now we can use the
same trick as minimum.
So now we're going to
set r equal to z minus n
ANDed with the negative of z
greater than or equal to n.
So if z is less
than n, then this
is going to return 0 in here.
And n ANDed with 0 is 0,
so we're just left with z.
And if z is greater
than or equal to n,
then this is going to be 1.
We negate that, we get negative
1, which is the all 1's word.
n ANDed with all 1's is just n.
So that is z minus n, which
will bring the result back
into range.
So any questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: It seems
like there essentially
is still a branch based
on the value of z.
So why would that be faster?
JULIAN SHUN: So this branch
here is just generating
either a Boolean value 1 or 0.
There's actually-- like the
code that you execute after it,
it's still the same
in either case.
So the branch misprediction
only hurts you
if there are two
different code paths.
In this version, there are
two different code paths,
because one is doing z and
one is doing z minus n.
So the next problem
we will look at
is computing or rounding a value
up to the nearest power of 2.
And this is just 2 to the
ceiling of log base 2 of n.
And recall that lg of n
is the log base 2 of n.
That's the notation we'll
be using in this class.
Here's some code to do this.
So we have our value of n here.
First, we're going
to decrement n.
And then we're going to do an OR
of n with n right-shifted by 1.
Then an OR with n and n
right-shifted by 2, and so on,
all the way up to 32.
So we do this for all
powers of 2 up to 32.
And then, finally, we
increment n at the end.
So let's look at an example
to see why this works.
So we're starting with
this value of n here.
First we're going
to decrement it.
And what that does is it flips
the rightmost 1 bit to 0,
and then it fills in all the
0's right of that with 1's.
And then when we
do this line, which
says n is equal to n ORed
with n right-shifted by 1,
that's essentially propagating
all of the 1 bits one position
to the right and
then ORing those in.
So we can see that
this 1 bit got copied
one position to the right.
This 1 bit got copied to
These 1's also propagate, but
since they were already 1's
it doesn't do anything.
For the next line, we're
propagating the 1 bits
two positions to the right.
So this 1 bit here
gets copied here.
This 1 gets copied
here, and so on.
And then the next line is
going to propagate bits
four positions the right.
Then 8, 16, and 32.
For this example here,
when I get to this line
I'm already done.
But, in general,
you have more bits
in a word, which I
can't fit on this slide.
And now we have
something that's exactly
one less than a power of 2.
And when we add 1 to that,
we just get a power of 2.
So we're going to zero
out all of these 1 bits
and then place a 1 here.
And this is exactly
the power of 2
that's greater than the value n.
So the first line
here is essentially
guaranteeing us that the
log nth minus 1 bit is set.
And we need that bit
to be set because we
want to propagate that
bit to all the positions
to the right of it.
And then these six lines here
are populating all the bits
to the right with 1's.
And then the last bit is
setting the log nth bit to 1
and then clearing all
of the other bits.
So one question is why
did we have to decrement n
at the beginning?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: In case n is
already [INAUDIBLE]..
JULIAN SHUN: Yes.
So if n is already a power of
2 and if we don't decrement n,
this is isn't going to work
because the log nth minus 1 bit
isn't set.
But if we decrement
n, then it's going
to guarantee us that
the log nth minus 1 bit
is set so that we can
propagate that to the right.
Any questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
JULIAN SHUN: Because,
in general, you're
using 64-bit words.
Here I don't have
that many bits here
because I can't fit
in on the slide,
but in general you
have more bits.
Let's look at another problem.
Here we want to compute the
mask of the least significant 1
in a word x.
So we want a mask
that has a 1 in only
the position of the least
significant 1 in x, and 0's
everywhere else.
So how can we do this?
So we can set r, the
result, equal to x
ANDed with negative x.
So let's look at why this works.
So here is x.
And recall negative x is the
two's complement of x plus 1.
So what we do is we flip all of
the bits up to the rightmost 1
but not including it, and then
we just copy all of the bits
over.
That's how we get
negative x from x.
And then now when we
compare x and negative x,
we see that all of the bits
when we AND them together
are going to be 0 except
for the bit at the position
corresponding to the least
significant 1 bit in x.
And that's going to be 1
since we're ANDing 1 and 1,
and everything else
is going to be 0.
And this will give us
the mask that we want.
So this works because the
binary representation of minus x
is just the one's
complement of x plus 1.
So now, a question is how can
we find the index of this bit?
So here I'm just generating
a mask that has a 1
in the least significant 1
in x, but it doesn't actually
tell me the index of this bit.
In other words, I want to find
the log base 2 of a power of 2.
So that's the problem
we want to solve,
and here's some code
that lets us do this.
So we have this constant
called the de Bruijn.
It's written in hex here.
And then we have this table
of size 64 called convert.
And now all we have to do is
multiply x by this de Bruijn
constant, right shift
it by 58 positions,
and then look up the result
in the convert table.
And that's going to give us the
log base 2 of the power of 2.
Any questions?
[STUDENTS LAUGH]
So this looks like magic to us.
So in the spirit of magic, we're
going to do a mathemagic trick.
And to do this trick, I'm
going to need five volunteers,
and the only
requirement is that you
need to be able to
follow directions.
So who wants to volunteer
for this magic trick?
Yes, 1, 2, 3, 4--
one more-- 5.
All right, come on up.
So line up here.
[STUDENTS APPLAUD]
Yes, just line up right here.
Can you move a little
bit over to the left?
OK, cool.
So today I have the pleasure of
welcoming Jess Ray, also known
as The Golden Raytio,
to join us for a lecture
and help us perform
this cool magic trick.
So let's give her a
round of applause.
[STUDENTS APPLAUD]
JESS RAY: I'm going to be doing
a little bit of magic trick
for you all today.
I'm going to be reading
your guys' minds.
And I know you're
looking skeptical,
but I'm hoping I can
convince you here.
So we'll get to that
part in a second.
But, first, the first
big step in reading minds
is you got to clear
the air, like get
rid of all the negative
vibes, all the bad energy.
Throw that out.
So I'm going to need a
little help from you guys
in doing this.
So, first, we have this
sweet little bell here.
Let's see.
Who wants the bell?
AUDIENCE: I'll take it, I guess.
JESS RAY: All right.
Can you hold that for a second?
So what this bell
is going to do is
help us get rid of some
of those negative ideas.
Can you give it a ring?
Oh yes.
So that painful ringing you're
hearing in your ears right now
is actually just clearing
up the air for us,
making it so I can
read your minds.
Thank you.
Stop that.
All right.
Next we have this
magic tone here.
Who would like to
give this a spin?
Can you shake that
around a couple of times?
Spin it.
Spin it with your wrist there,
like-- you can go like this.
There we go.
All right.
Perfect.
It's feeling a
little clearer here.
I can start-- you can start
getting things off your mind.
Don't worry, I won't tell
anybody what you're thinking.
Oh, let's see what else.
Let me channel the spirits.
Help me out here.
All right, I'm feeling good.
All right.
So what we're going to
be doing is, as I said,
reading your mind.
I'm going to be doing
this by giving you cards,
and I'm going to tell
you what each of you
are holding for the card.
So I have some cards here.
Well, I guess these
are a little small.
Let's see.
Go a little bigger.
Meh.
Here we go.
Let's-- this looks better.
All right.
These are kind of heavy.
Get rid of these junk ones
up here, all the junk.
All right.
So I need your help for this.
So what I want you to
do is take the cards
and cut the deck as
many times as you want.
So, basically, just going
like that however much.
Just don't actually
shuffle them randomly.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Here you go.
JESS RAY: All right, cool.
So now I'm going to
hand each of you a card.
Don't let me see it.
Feel free to look at it.
There you go.
All right.
So the reason I'm wearing
this awesome onesie
is this helps me sweat
out the bad energy.
I'm literally
sweating right now.
But there's one more piece that
we need for this mind reading
trick.
The magic hat.
All right.
See if this fits on my head.
There we go.
Where's the switch?
All right.
Turn it on.
All right, I'm
feeling good here.
All right, you guys ready?
All right.
So I do need a little help
getting this trick started.
So if you are
holding a red card,
can you just raise your hand?
So no?
Who's got the red card?
Red, red.
You don't have red?
OK.
All right.
So the first one
and the third one.
All right.
So let me handle the mind
reading abilities here.
Now what I'm going to do is
I'm going to go left to right
and tell you what
you're holding.
Obviously, I know the color, but
I'll tell you what suit it is,
and also I will tell
you what the number is.
So first card, obviously
I know you have a red.
Hmm.
I'm feeling a diamond
and also a four?
AUDIENCE: That was it.
JESS RAY: Yes.
All right.
Good start, good start.
Got to-- got to think about
what the next one is here.
All right.
So I know you had a black card.
Let's see.
Black of spades.
Is it the ace of spades?
Oh yes.
There we go.
All right.
So back to red.
This one, let's see.
Red, diamond, two.
All right, all right.
We're doing good so far.
Can I get the last two?
All right, let's see
what we can do here.
All right, black, club, four.
All right.
Last one, last one.
Oh, it's going to
be a tough one.
Black, spade, eight.
[STUDENTS APPLAUD]
And if we had time, I
could you mystify you
and go through the rest of the
deck, but we won't do that.
So thank you guys very much.
I hope your minds were blown.
Yes.
So me collect the
cards back from you.
Thank you.
All right.
Now I can get out of
this and stop sweating.
[STUDENTS APPLAUD]
JULIAN SHUN: It's
pretty cool, right?
So why does this actually work?
To know why this
trick actually works,
we need to first study what
a de Bruijn sequence is.
So a de Bruijn
sequence s of length 2
to the k is a cyclic bit
sequence such that each
of the 2 to the k possible
bit strings of length k
occurs exactly once
as a substring in s.
So this a pretty long
definition, so let's
look at an example.
So here is a de Bruijn
sequence for k equals 3.
So the length of this sequence
is 8 because 2 to the 3 is 8.
And you can see that each of the
possible three-bit substrings
occurs exactly once in this
cyclic bit string of length 8.
So it wraps around
and you can consider
this as a cyclic string.
So we see that 000
appears at position 0.
001 is at position 1.
Then 010 is at position 6.
011 is at position 2.
100 is at position 7.
101 is at 5.
110 is at 4.
And then 111 is at 3.
So all of the 8 possible
substrings of length 3
occur exactly once in
this de Bruijn sequence.
So now we're going to create
this convert table of length 8.
In general, this
will be 2 to the k.
And here, k is 3.
And in this convert table, what
we're storing in each position
is the index in the
de Bruijn sequence
where the bit string
corresponding to that position
starts in the de
Bruijn sequence.
So here we see that convert of
2 is 6 because the bit string
corresponding to 2 is 010,
and that begins at position 6
in the de Bruijn sequence.
We also see that convert
of 4 is 7 because 4 is 100,
and that begins at position
7 in the de Bruijn sequence.
Now we have this convert table.
And recall that we're
trying to compute
the log base 2 of a power of 2.
So hopefully you
guys remember that.
So the way to do
this is we're going
to multiply the
de Bruijn sequence
constant by this power of 2.
So let's say we're
working with the integer
16, which is 2 to the 4.
So we're going to multiply
this de Bruijn sequence by 2
to the 4.
And when we multiply
by a power of 2,
that's the same
as left shifting.
So that's going to left shift
the de Bruijn sequence four
positions to the left.
And then now we want to
see which of the eight
possible substrings appears at
the beginning of this sequence.
And after we do
the left shift, 110
appears at the beginning
of the sequence.
And we want to extract
this out, and we
can do that by right
shifting five positions.
And 110 is just 6.
And we can figure out where
5 starts in this de Bruijn
sequence by looking it
up in the convert table.
We see that convert of 6 is 4.
So the string 110
appears starting
at position 4 in the
de Bruijn sequence,
and that means that we
did a left shift by 4
in the first step, and
that gives us the log base
2 of the power of 2,
because the only reason why
we did a left shift by 4
is because the power of 2
was 2 to the 4.
So this returns us the
log base 2 of the integer
that we started with.
And one thing to
note is that it's
important to start with all
0's in this sequence here,
because we're representing
this as a cyclic bit sequence.
So when we do a
left shift, we need
to make sure that the values
that fill in on the right side
are correct.
So notice that in the sixth
and seventh positions,
we need 0's at the
end when we overflow.
So because the de
Bruijn sequence
starts with all 0's, when
we do the left shift,
it's automatically filling
with 0's, giving us
the correct substring.
So the magic trick that Jess
did had 32 cards, and in that
case k was equal to 5.
And the cards were arranged
according to a de Bruijn
sequence of length 32.
And each of the
cards corresponded
to one particular bit
string of length 5.
And the color of the card
corresponded to the bit.
So when she asked you what
the color of your card was,
she could determine
the bits corresponding
to the first card
in the sequence
because she has the 5 bits
corresponding to that card.
And then with that she
has some clever way
to determine the
rest of the cards.
So that's how the
de Bruijn sequence
is related to the magic
trick that you just saw.
Any questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: The de
Bruijn sequence,
do you need to do
cyclic translation?
JULIAN SHUN: So there could be
multiple de Bruijn sequences.
We just need one particular
de Bruijn sequence
to make this bit trick work.
Yes.
So this example is
just for k equals 3.
And the code I showed you
before, that was for k
equals 8, so you can
do up to 64-bit words.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: How do we know
that the sequence exists?
JULIAN SHUN: So there
is a mathematical proof
that says that.
I can give you some
pointers so that you
can look at it after class.
But there's a proof that
says that for any length
there is a de Bruijn sequence.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, I
missed the procedure.
So how exactly do you
determine the log base 2?
JULIAN SHUN: So we have--
we're starting with some
integer that is a power of 2.
So when we multiply
by that power of 2,
it's left-shifting by
the log base 2 of that.
And then we can determine how
much we left-shifted because we
know--
we can just look at the first
three bits of this sequence
after we did the
left shift, and then
look at where that
three-bit sequence appears
in the original de Bruijn
sequence before we shifted it.
And to do that, you can look
it up in the convert table.
This is what we did when we
looked up the bit string 110
in the convert table.
And that tells us that it
starts in the fourth position.
That means that we
left-shifted by 4,
and that means that the
value of n was 2 to the 4.
Does that make sense?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So just to
clarify this only works
if you multiply the
sequence by a power of 2,
then it gives you back
which power of 2 it was?
JULIAN SHUN: Yes.
So this only works if you're
starting with a power of 2.
So if it's not a power
of 2, this doesn't work.
Any other questions?
Yes.
So if it's not a power
of 2, you can round it up
to the nearest power
of 2 using another bit
trick that we saw earlier.
And then you can use
this bit trick here.
The performance
of this bit trick
is limited by the performance
of multiplication and table
lookup.
So you have to do
a multiplication
by some constant,
and then you have
to do table lookup in
this convert table.
So a table lookup does
a memory reference,
which could be expensive.
And nowadays there's actually
a hardware instruction
to compute this, so
you don't actually
have to implement this trick.
But this trick is
still pretty cool.
And in the past this
is how you would do it
before there was a hardware
instruction that came out.
So let's look at
another problem.
So this is the n queens problem.
How many of you have
seen this before?
Yes.
So many of you have
seen this before.
As a reminder, we're
trying to place n queens
on an n by n chessboard so that
no queen attacks another queen.
In other words, there
are no two queens
in any row, any column,
or any diagonal.
And, commonly, we want
to count the number
of possible solutions
to the n queens problem
for a particular value of n.
And in this example here,
this is a valid configuration.
You can check, for
each of the queens,
they can't attack any
other queen on the board.
So one common strategy for
implementing the n queens
algorithm is to
use backtracking.
We're going to try
placing queens row by row.
We know that there can
only be one queen per row,
so we just need to determine
which position in that row
the queen will appear in.
And then if we can't
place a queen in any row,
then we backtrack.
So, for example,
in the first row,
we'll just place the queen
in the first position,
because there's no
queens on the board
yet, so the first
position is valid.
For the second row,
we're going to try
to place in the first position,
but we can't place it there
because then it will
attack the first queen.
And then the second
position is also invalid,
so the third position is where
we place the second queen.
Now, for the third
row we're going
to check the positions until
we get to one that's valid,
and this is going to
be the fifth position.
Do this again.
Here we can do it in
the second position.
For the fifth row, let's see
where this is going to end up.
OK.
So it goes in the
fourth position.
What about the sixth row?
Whoops.
So all of the eight
positions are invalid,
because if we place the queen
in any of those positions,
it's going to attack one of the
queens that we already placed.
So now we're going to backtrack.
We're going to find another
position for the fifth queen.
So let's try some
more positions.
So we can place it at the end.
Now we try again.
All right.
So, unfortunately, we
couldn't find a position
for the sixth row again.
We have to backtrack.
But we already tried all the
positions in the fifth row,
so we backtrack
to the fourth row.
And you get the idea.
And then whenever we find
a configuration where
all eight queens are valid, then
we increment some counter by 1.
And at the end we just
return this counter,
which tells us the number
of solutions to the n queens
puzzle.
So you can implement
this quite easily using
a recursive procedure.
You can implement this
backtracking search.
But one question
is how should we
represent the board to
facilitate efficient queen
placement?
So one way to
represent the board
is to use an array
of n squared bytes.
And for each byte,
we just have a 1
if there is a queen in that
position, and 0 otherwise.
Is there a better way
to represent the board?
AUDIENCE: You can
track all of the bits
such that a 1 bit
represents a queen
at some place on the board?
JULIAN SHUN: Yes.
So that's a good answer.
So instead of using
bytes, we can use bits,
because the value
can only be 0 or 1.
We only need one bit
to represent that.
So we can just have an
array of n squared bits.
Is there a better
way to do this?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: You could
just say in each row
where a queen is with a byte?
JULIAN SHUN: Yes.
So good answer.
So a better way to do this is
to just use an array of n bytes.
Because we know that on each
row there can only be one queen,
so we just need to store
the position of that queen.
So we have an array of n
bytes, one byte for each row,
and then you just used the
byte to store the position
of the queen in that row.
It turns out, to
implement this algorithm,
there's a even more
compact representation,
which is to use three-bit
vectors of size n, 2n minus 1,
and 2n minus 1.
So let's see how this works.
So the first bit vector we're
going to use is of length n.
We're going to call
this the down vector.
And the down vector
just stores a 1
in the columns that have a
queen in it and 0 in the columns
that are empty.
And then when we want to
check whether placing a queen
is safe in any
position, we first
have to check whether
that column is empty.
And you can do this
by ANDing the down bit
vector with 1 left-shifted by
c, where c is a column where
you want to place the queen.
And if that's
nonzero, that means
there's already a queen in that
column and you can't place it.
Otherwise, we're going to
have to do another check,
and we're going to create this
other bit vector called left.
The length of this bit
vector is 2n minus 1.
And it stores a 1
in the diagonal that
has a queen in it,
and 0's otherwise.
And there are 2n minus
2 possible diagonals.
And then now, when
we want to place
a queen in row r
and column c, we
can check whether it's safe
by doing left ANDed with 1
left-shifted by r plus c.
And this is going to be
nonzero if there is already
a queen in that
particular diagonal.
So in that case, we can't
place a queen there.
And, otherwise, we're going
to do a final check using
this right bit vector, which
is essentially the same
but we're looking
at the diagonals
going down to the right.
So, again, we have a 1 in the
diagonals that have a queen
and 0's otherwise.
And then now the check is
going to be right ANDed with 1
left-shifted by n
minus 1 minus r plus c.
And if a particular
candidate passes all three
of these checks, then
we know that there's not
going to be a conflict
and we can place the queen
in that particular position.
So this is a bit
vector representation.
You actually still
have to write the code
to count the number of
queens using this bit vector
representation,
and it's actually
an interesting exercise.
So I encourage you to
try to do this at home.
But I just told you about the
bit vector representation.
So any questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Could you just
repeat what the down vector bit
hack was for figuring
out [INAUDIBLE]??
JULIAN SHUN: Yes.
So the down vector,
it stores a 1
in the columns that have a
queen in it and 0's otherwise.
And what you do is, if you want
to place a queen in column c,
you first create the
mask 1 left-shifted by c.
And then you AND it
with a down vector.
And that's going to
be nonzero if there's
a queen in that column.
Any other questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Why isn't
there a horizontal one?
JULIAN SHUN: So it turns
out that you don't need.
Just these three checks
is enough to guarantee--
guarantee that you can
place a queen in a position
if it passes all
three of the checks.
Yes.
So a fourth check would
just be redundant.
AUDIENCE: So we don't
need a horizontal one
because we're not placing
two queens in the same row.
JULIAN SHUN: Yes.
That's true.
Good point.
Yes.
So we're only placing one
queen in each particular row.
So let's look at
another problem.
This is called population
count, or pop count for short.
And the problem here is we
want to count the number of 1
bits in some word x.
Here's a way to do this that
repeatedly eliminates the least
significant 1 bit in a word.
So we have this for loop
where r is initialized to 0.
And we're going to repeat
this loop until x becomes 0.
And then each time we go through
this loop, we increment r.
And inside the loop
we're going to set
x equal to x ANDed
with x minus 1.
And this is going to clear the
least significant 1 bit in x.
So let's look at an example.
So let's say we have
this value here for x.
Well, to get x minus 1, we
flip the rightmost 1 bit
in x from a 1 to 0.
And then we fill in all of the
bits to the right of that with
1's.
And then now when we AND
those two things together,
we're going to copy all of the
bits up to the rightmost 1.
And then for the rightmost
1, we're going to zero it out
because we're ending with a 0.
And then all of the bits
to the right of that
are still going to be 0.
So x ANDed with
x minus 1 is just
going to get rid of the
least significant 1 bit.
And then we repeat this
process until x becomes 0.
In that case we've already
eliminated all the 1's and we
know the answer,
which is stored in r.
Questions?
So this code will be pretty
fast if the number of 1 bits
is small, but the
running time is
proportional to the number
of 1 bits in a word.
So in the worst case, if most
of the bits are set to 1,
then you're going to need a lot
of iterations to run this code.
So let's look at a more
efficient way to do this.
This is to use table lookup.
So we're going to create
a table of size 256, which
stores for each 8-bit
word the number of 1's
in that 8-bit word.
So we have all possible 8-bit
words stored in this table.
And then now, to get the
number of 1 bits in x,
for every 8-bit
substring in x, we're
going to look it up in this
count table and add it to r.
And then we're going
to right-shift x by 8
so that we can
get the next word.
And then when x becomes
0, we know we're done.
So that's table lookup.
And the performance here
depends on the size of x.
If we have a 64-bit
word, we need
to do this at most eight times,
whereas in the initial code
we might have to do it 64
times if we had 64 1 bits.
The cost of this code is
bottlenecked by the memory
operations, because this table
here is stored in memory.
So every time you access
it you have to go to memory
to fetch the value there.
And here are some
approximate costs
for accessing memory in various
levels of the hierarchy.
If something's stored in
register, it's very fast.
It only takes you 1 cycle.
If it's stored in L1
cache, it's about 4 cycles,
L2 cache about 10 cycles,
L3 cache about 50 cycles.
And then, finally, if you have
to go to DRAM because it's not
in cache, it's much more
expensive, 150 cycles.
It's an order of
magnitude slower
than doing something--
fetching something that's
already stored in a register.
So let's now look at a third
way to do population count where
we don't actually have
to go to cache or DRAM.
Essentially, we can do
everything in registers.
So here's how you do it.
So we're going to create
these five masks--
or six masks, from M0 up to M5.
And these masks-- the
values of these masks
are shown in the comments here.
In this notation
here, x to the k
just means x repeated k times.
So the mask M5 has 32
0's, followed by 32 1's.
The mask M0 has the bit
string 01 repeated 32 times,
and so on.
After we create
these masks, we're
going to execute these six
instructions at the bottom,
and this is going to give us
the number of 1's in the word.
So let's do an example
to see how this works.
So let's say we start
with this bit string here.
In the first step,
what we're going to do
is we're going to AND
x with the mask M0.
And then we're also going
to AND x right-shifted
by 1 with the mask M0.
and recall that the mask M0
is just 01 repeated 32 times,
and therefore the mask is
essentially extracting all
of the even bits.
So x ANDed with M0 gives
us all of the even bits.
And then when we right-shift
x by 1 and AND it with M0,
that's going to give
us all the odd bits.
And then we're going to
line those two things up
and add them together.
And the result of
doing this is it's
going to tell us for every
group of two bits the number
of 1 bits in that group.
So now for each of
these pairs of bits,
it's telling us how
many of them are 1.
So in the leftmost group
here, we add two 1's.
So the result of adding 1
and 1 is 1 0, which is 2.
For the rightmost group, we have
two 0's, and the count there is
00.
And this is the same for
all of the other groups.
So this gives us the number of
1's in every pair of positions.
Now we're going to AND
the result with M1.
And we're going to right-shift
it by 2 and also AND it with M1
and add those two
things together.
And M1 is a mask that will
give us the bottom two bits
in every group of four bits.
So when we right-shift
x by 2, that's
giving us the top two bits.
And then now we
add those together,
and it will give us the
count of the number of 1
bits in every group of size 4.
And these counts are stored
in the result here now.
So you can verify that
each of these groups
has the count of the
number of 1 bits.
So, for example,
we have 100 here.
And this is correct since
there are four 1 bits.
Now we do this again
with the mask M2.
That's going to
give us the counts
for all groups of size 8.
Then we go to groups of size 16.
And then, finally, we
add these two together,
giving us the number of bits
in this group of size 32.
And this is actually
the pop count.
So the value here is 17.
And you can verify that
there are indeed 17 1's
in the input word x.
Any questions?
So the performance
of this code, which
is based on parallel
divide and conquer,
is going to be proportional
to log base 2 of w,
where w is the word length.
Because on every step I'm
doubling the size of my groups.
And after I do this log base 2
w times, I have the whole group.
In the first two instructions
that I executed here,
I have to actually
do the AND separately
for x right-shifted by 1 and x,
and also x right-shifted by 2
and x, and then
add them together,
because there is
an overflow issue.
The overflow issue is that
the size of the groups
here might not be large
enough to actually store
the count of the number
of 1 bits in that group.
But once I get to
the larger groups,
the count can always be
stored in a group of that size
and I don't need to
worry about overflow.
So for the last four
lines, I can actually
save one instruction.
I don't need to
do the AND twice.
So it turns out that most
modern machines nowadays
have an intrinsic pop count
instruction implemented
in hardware, which is
faster than anything
you can code yourself.
And you can access this
pop count instruction
via compiler intrinsics,
for example in GCC or Clang.
And in GCC, it's
__builtin_popcount.
One warning though is that
if you write this code using
these intrinsics, if
you try to compile
the code on a machine
that doesn't support it,
your code isn't
going to compile.
So it makes your
code less portable.
But this intrinsic is faster
than the parallel divide
and conquer version.
So one question is, how
can you get the log base
2 of a power of 2 quickly
using a pop count instruction?
So instead of using the
de Bruijn sequence trick.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: You decrement
then you pop count.
JULIAN SHUN: Yes.
So what you do is you subtract
1 from the power of 2,
and that's going to flood all
of the lower bits with 1's.
And then now when you
execute pop count,
it's going to count the number
of 1's, and that gives us
the log base 2 of
the power of 2.
So good answer.
So those all the
bit tricks I'm going
to be talking about today.
There's a lot of
resources online if you're
interested in learning more.
There's this really
good website maintained
by Sean Eron Anderson.
There's also the
Knuth's textbook, which
has some bit tricks in there.
There's a chess
programming website which
has a lot of cool bit tricks.
Some of those are used in
implementing chess programs.
And then, finally, this book
called Hacker's Delight.
So we'll be playing around
with many of these bit
tricks in project 1,
so happy bit hacking.